Big news Morgans is a former member of the
Roger Pirates.
In other words a member of the most powerful
and influential pirate crew in history.
Someone who fought side be side with the likes
of Shanks, Rayleigh and Roger himself, reaching
the last island of the grand line.
And just like Shanks, Crocus or Rayleigh,
he has worked hard behind the scenes to make
Roger's last will come true and has helped
Luffy get to where he is today, using his
influence on the world government and his
monopoly on information in the one piece world.
This sounds of course absolutely preposterous
and I thought the exact same thing when I
first stumbled across the idea on my subreddit
wild anime theories.
However, as reddit user LedgeEndDairy points
out correctly, there is actually surprisingly
much evidence pointing in exactly that direction.
And when you follow the breadcrumbs, it only
leaves us with one possible conclusion: Big
News Morgan is very likely a Roger Pirate.
To be precise one of these men right here.
I'll tell you why in a second.
Also if you haven't yet, make sure to subscribe.
It's free.
Big News Morgan is not just anyone, but one
of the most influential and powerful people
in the world.
And we really have no idea what he actually
looks like.
After all, Oda-sensei has confirmed that Morgans
isn't some type of intelligent animal, like
for example a member of the minks, but a human
that has eaten the bird bird zoan fruit model
albatross.
In other words, similar to Chopper, Morgan
is constantly in his hybrid form.
So he could be someone we have seen in the
story before without ever realising it.
Here's what we know so far about Big News
Morgans:
He is the president of the World Economy News
Paper.
In other words, he is the one who prints the
newspapers that are being distributed across
the world by the infamous news coo, that's
the name of the birds that distribute the
news across the one piece world.
While Morgans and his team look very quirky,
you shouldn't let yourself be fooled.
He is incredibly powerful.
This world is fully controlled by a global
world government, that not only re-writes
history to fit its own purposes, but also
goes extremely hard against anyone trying
to share truths and news that could harm its
power - just ask the scholars of Ohara.
Controlling Information and keeping the citizens
of the world badly informed has probably been
the governments most powerful tool to stay
in power for the past 800 years.
And yet, here we have this man, that runs
the worlds biggest newspaper.
That makes Morgan one of the most dangerous
and influential people on the planet.
I'm really curious why the government has
allowed him to build such a monopoly.
My guess would be that Morgan used to play
along nicely with the government and help
them spread their propaganda.
We have already seen that the government tried
to bribe him and that they had an undercover
agent at his office.
I think it is only quite recently that Morgans
has gone so openly against the Gorosei.
Another reason however, is that Morgans is
one of the emperors of the underworld, where
the government, countries and pirates all
trade weapons, information and anything else
imaginable away from the public eye.
Morgans deals with information.
Not only does he have the power to shape global
opinions, but he can also blackmail others
by sharing sensitive information.
For many years, he was part of the system,
that helped the Yonko and the government alike
in controlling the news.
And even though his power is mostly information,
he is also physically quite strong, having
no problem what so ever dealing with the Cypher
Pole agent that threatened him or standing
side by side with some of the strongest people
in the story.
He knew exactly that Stussy was an undercover
agent as well and what she was capable of,
and yet he was not in the slightest intimidated
by her presence.
It was only with the end of Whole Cake Island
that Morgans started doing his own thing.
He revealed his interest in the supernova
and started cheering for Luffy in particular
to become the next pirate king.
Now you could try to argue that all of these
things could simply be the characteristics
of a cunning and tough journalist, who just
wants to get money and excitement out of it
for himself.
However, this is where things get a little
fishy.
First of all, what we mentioned earlier, it's
really strange that he never leaves his hybrid
form.
This is clearly to protect his true identity.
The only question is, who could Morgans be
that would be problematic for his job?
It must be someone who would get him intro
trouble either with the government or cost
him his credibility with his readers.
This journalist, who has a secret identity,
should be familiar to you.
It's basically the superman trope.
Now I don't think that Morgans is the lurking
legend or anything, but I do think that this
is Oda-sensei's take on it.
And his fruit itself is also quite suspicious.
Morgan is an Albatros devil fruit user.
The Albatros is notorious for its long-distance
flight abilities, and yet Morgan here, can't
fly.
Allegedly.
We also know for a fact, that Morgan was the
one who reported on Luffy's exploits on whole
cake island and who declared him as the next
emperor before he made his way to Wano.
In fact, we can assume that it was his newspaper
that has been distributing news about the
straw hats exploits throughout the story.
And as far as I remember, the straw hats have
always been portrayed in quite a positive
light, presented as this powerful crew of
upcoming pirates, that bring turmoil to wherever
they go.
And while it's still unclear whether or not
Morgans has any influence on the bounties
themselves, he seems to be the one to print
and distribute all bounty posters.
He was clearly the one who put the photo of
Gear5 Luffy on his new wanted poster and has
included the D in his name.
Now all of that strongly hints at Big News
Morgan having a secret agenda
and a secret identity.
However, why do I say with such certainty
that he might be a Roger pirate in disguise?
You better put your seatbelt on for this one.
Let's begin with the matter of Roger finding
the one piece and becoming the pirate king.
Since it's the premise for the entire story,
I think none of us ever really questioned
how Roger got so famous in the first place.
Because when you think about it, that's quite
fishy too.
Roger was the first person in 800 years to
reach the last island.
There he found the one piece and named the
island Laugh Tale, based on Joy Boys story
he read there.
However, why would anyone believe him?
Who confirmed that this actually happened
and that Roger didn't make it up?
Someone had to actually tell the press that
this happened, because Roger clearly wasn't
the one who told the world.
He read his new epithet 'Pirate King' in the
news paper himself and found it amusing.
The easiest explanation here, is that the
news about Roger were spread by someone who
was there.
A journalist, who accompanied Roger on his
trip, either because Roger was nice enough
to let them or because Roger himself wanted
to make a name for himself.
And I believe that this person was Morgan.
The man who became famous for breaking the
story and naming Roger pirate king.
This would explain Morgan's obsession with
Luffy und the race for the next pirate king
perfectly as well.
As you know, Roger was waiting for the return
of Joy Boy.
And in anticipation of his death, he did everything
in his power to ease the way for his return.
He fathered at least one child with ace, that
he hoped would become joy boy later.
He then tasked his men with carrying on his
will and prepare joy boy's arrival.
He sent out shanks to find the right person
and get his hands on the Nika Nika fruit.
Shanks was to give that person the fruit and
entrust them with Roger's hat.
He then stationed Crocus at the entrance to
the grand line to scout for the person with
the straw hat, tell them about the final island
and teach them how to navigate the first half
of the Grand Line.
He then stationed his right hand man Rayleigh
at the halfway point on Sabaody.
Rayleigh would also identify Joy Boy by his
hat, train him and help him cross over into
the new world, the second part of the grand
line.
And one possibility is that his third in command,
Scopper Gaban is waiting on Roadstar island
to teach Joy Boy about Laugh Tale and the
final journey there.
But that's a story for a different video.
Because as you've figured out by now, Morgan
would fit this pattern perfectly.
He has helped to spread Luffy's legend.
He is the one who declared him an emperor
and who believes that he will be the next
pirate king.
Now we have heard many people believe in Luffy
finding the one piece, but Morgans is the
only person, that has never met Luffy in person
and still believes it?
Why, because he also recognised Roger's straw
hat.
And so Morgan has made sure to favour Luffy
in public perception and ease his way.
How so you may ask?
Well remember how Rayleigh, Shanks and co
keep up with LUffy's development.
We have seen Shanks more than once read about
Luffy in the news.
It seems to be his trusted source of info
about him for some reason.
I assume you would also expect Shanks to keep
eyes on Luffy some other way, but he seems
suspiciously content with the regular newspaper.
Well if Morgan was his former crew mate, part
of the same mission to help Joy Boy, then
of course Shanks would trust that information.
Morgan most likely would put it in there for
other members of the Roger crew to see.
I also want you to think about the aftermath
of the war at Marineford.
Luffy returns to marine HQ to literally send
a message to the rest of the crew, to train
for 2 years and meet back at sabaody strong
enough to take on the new world.
But that wasn't actually luffy's idea.
Yup, you guessed it, it was Rayleigh's.
Rayleigh proposed to Luffy to get a picture
taken at Marineford with the message on his
arm visible to the cameras.
And it was Rayleigh who accompanied him there.
Yes, it was a real ballsy stunt of Luffy to
come back, but there was absolutely no guarantee
that it would make the news or that they would
use that exact picture of Luffy with the message
clearly visible.
What if the government wanted to cover this
up as well, avoiding the humiliation of having
Luffy back there and having him escape a second
time.
If Morgan, the one curating the news, was
an ally of Rayleigh however, then of course
he could ensure that the straw hats receive
Luffy's message.
Rayleigh and Morgan staged the entire thing
as a massive media stunt.
Luffy rings the bell, lays down flowers and
then takes of his hat to pay respect to those
who have fallen, while the marines charge
in like idiots.
The reporters there have no chance, but portray
luffy as the noble mysterious rookie, who
has come with Jinbe and Silvers Rayleigh.
And one of the reporters even literally says:
'This is big news!'
Morgan's catchphrase before we ever get to
meet him.
And once again, we see the marines reacting
to this news breaking, saying that the article
already has spread around the world.
So once again, just like on whole cake island
and on wano news about Luffy gets out, that
the government wanted to keep quiet.
And Morgan being a Roger pirate also would
explain one of the biggest plot holes in the
story: Why is Luffy's full name always displayed
on his wanted posters?
We know that the Gorosei want to keep the
D initial a secret.
INCLUDING for Luffy, as we learned after Wano.
Yet Luffy has been wanted as Monkey D. Luffy
on every single bounty poster.
The government wanted to hide the D initial
so hard, they even renamed Gol D Roger into
Gold Roger.
They also surely wanted to hide Luffy being
related to Garp.
So, if the Government would have had its way,
I bet Luffy could have been just LUFFY on
the bounty poster, like Shanks is just Shanks.
If you have someone in the news 'accidentally'
publishing the D initial however, who operates
on his own terms, and who wants the D clan
out in the open, that would explain a lot.
Morgan is the missing piece linking Rayleigh
and Shanks and the other members of the Roger
pirates that are working to make Luffy the
next pirate king.
Oda hides his appearance, because we have
now met all of Rogers crew through Oden's
flashback.
And age wise it also fits pretty smoothly.
He was in his early 20s during Roger's journey
to laugh tale.
So who out of Rogers men could Morgans possibly
be?
I have 4 candidate for you: First is this
guy here, Petermoo.
He has a very similar body shape to Morgans
and is also earring a feathered hat.
Then there is Momora, who also wears a hat,
that is strangely shaped like a bird's head.
There is Moon Isaac Jr, who has this beak
shaped nose and who might be based on Issac
Newton, who discovered gravity, opposed to
flight.
And finally there is Spencer, who I just threw
in there, because he looks pretty much like
a male version of Nami and I wanted to mention
that.
One idea I have seen thrown around is that
Morgan might have been the thing inside the
giant egg, that was on board of the Roger
pirates ship, however that is a whole different
beast.
And if you want to know what it is, you really
can't miss out on this video right here.